c'est fini pour vale hostile et 118
employés en grève depuis trois semaines
se retrouve donc sans emploi un
cataclysme
j'ai pris une décision dans une boîte
les gens appellent ils choisissent une
chanson et nous on la livre à la
personne de leurs patientes avant juin à
laisser les gens chanter et en plus être
payés pour ça oui si oui direct quand la
musique tu te sens
tu respires ici la plus bas quand elle
ne triche pas ouais c'est mieux je le
sens non non non
rider jour là même si on sentait qu'on
vient chez vous on chante des chansons
qui me ferait du bien de chanter avec
vous attend 1140 mal pour de se mettre
debout pour annoncer que le début ça va
aller crescendo
la réponse est le sourire de ravoir tu
souris
j'ai une livraison pour marc c'est moi
c'est un message de mélanie marque je me
casse adieu du conte
est passé notre amour égard un p'tit
coup à la maison en dix fois plus gros
que n'importe quel mon nom c'est à
l'aise
je me voyais déjà les gens ce qu'ils
veulent ces bouffées toi ce que tu le
revends c'est de l'air
c'est de la merde ma vie c'est une super
idée des vrais des changements hier la
preuve personne n'y avait pensé avant
maintenant je comprends pourquoi
bon allez bosser là on a des livraisons
en ferrain du front pour qui je me
prends pour celui qui a eu l'idée de
cette boîte est en route sans tout ce
qu'on a fait en idées elle vaut rien
du monde quelque chose un gros truc
et on continue
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
j'ai un message de la part de votre mari
et ils vous dédie cette chanson
elle est tombée toute seule
[Musique]